[Musique]
une fille il veut se marier avec elle
quoi non j'ai jamais dit ça tu l'as dit
avec tes yeux
ils doivent être en pleine migration une
migration c'est n'importe quoi ça y est
tu es insupportable parce que j'ai
trouvé un endroit où on vit en sécurité
quel
de quel père mettrait ses petits en
danger pour la seule et unique raison de
pouvoir passer des vacances dans les
Caraïbes je ne gâcherai pas ma vie sous
prétexte que tu as peur de quitter cet
état
c'est parti contre les plus marrières
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pourquoi on est les seuls à voler dans
cette direction
c'est quoi cet endroit
[Musique]
je vous ai promis de l'aventure et vous
voyez j'ai tenu ma promesse
qu'est-ce que c'est du canard alors
orange
c'est toi avec tes oranges
[Musique]
tu es assez grande pour faire ça dans le
ciel elle veut faire la grosse
commission
tous les oiseaux font ça dans
le cirque il est hors de question
d'atterrir
vous êtes sûr que
vert dépêche-toi ou on part sans toi
d'accord
on est complètement perdu on voudrait
aller en Jamaïque venez les tourtereaux
suivez le guide on va pas risquer nos
plumes dans cette ville de fou furieux
restez toujours près de moi et tout se
passera bien
je vais bien oui non non je vais bien on
va y arriver